good evening it's thursday october
twenty ninth and with halloween right
around the corner i've got four spooky
news updates for you first up for
survival game outlast confirmed its
sequel today via teaser trailer
independent developer red barrels
announced today outlast 2 a sequel to
2013 first person survival horror game
there's an upside down burning cross and
a narrator reciting bible passages from
the book of revelations the game aims to
take players on a twisted new journey
into the depths of the human mind and
dark secret no conflict is ever black
and white but once the dust has settled
the victors get to decide who was right
and who was wrong reads a line from the
game's description who is good and who
is evil human nature punishes us to
extremes of violence and depravity which
we justified by divine inspiration from
a promise of paradise to come or rises
from desperation and blind faith outlast
to will test your faith pushing players
took place we're going mad is the only
sane thing to do outlast 2 is slated to
launch in fall 2016 trick or treats well
rockstar is treating us to a special
halloween update for GTA 5 Rockstar
Games announced today GTA online
Halloween surprise which sees the
release of spooky items such as cars and
mass as well as a slasher themed
adversary mode like GTA online's most
recent update lowriders this one is
coming exclusively to xbox one and ps4
and PC GTA online's Halloween surprise
adds too creepy vehicles lurcher hearse
and frankenstein the halloween update
also brings new masks for heist you'll
find these in new Halloween masks
category in the monster section in
addition the event also introduces a new
slasher adversary mode which supports up
to eight players GTA online Halloween
surprise event started today october
29th and it runs until november 16
steam joined in on the spooky
festivities today by announcing their
Halloween sale today steam kicked off
its halloween sale discounting 52 games
officially featured on the page notable
horrors include h1z1 at 16 bucks dying
light for 30 and other games like stoma
alien isolation and the forest there's
other games that aren't technically
horror but worth checking out like GTA 5
for 40 bucks Ark survival evolved for 20
or The Witcher finally you can consider
games that have nothing to do with
horror like city skylines and broforce
they're all on sale until November
second and to round off our spooky news
updates we've got concept images from
fallout 4 wait that's not fair Bethesda
has shared new images from the 368 page
art of fallout 4 book which it produced
in collaboration with dark house the
developers also shared the books forward
written by the lead artist the book
represents an opportunity for us to
share with you a bit of the history
behind this world how it is evolved over
those years and why some of the artistic
choices were made the art of Fallout 4
goes on sale December 22nd the regular
version sells for 50 while a limited
edition can be purchased for 85 you can
buy both through the Bethesda store so
that's it for today's spooky episode but
you won't wanna miss tomorrow we'll be
doing our annual Halloween costume
contest see you then
you